[Music]
very bad news for fans of Quentin
Tarantino apparently Quentin Tarantino
decided to pull the plug on his next
film when he learned an early draft of
the script was leaked online yeah now
he's filing a lawsuit against a web site
for posting a link to the script this is
really tough for Quentin Tannen you know
but I know how he feels
okay earlier today the script for a
sketch that we were going to air on
tonight's show was also leaked online
and honestly now that it was leaked I
don't see the point in going through
with the sketch since it's already out
there yeah you know on websites
everywhere in fact can you guys come out
here
guys I know you were supposed to be in
that sketch but we're just not gonna do
it I'm I'm really sorry sorry oh yeah I
hated doing that I just I hope they're
okay
Andre quit acting and started his whole
pasta catering business let's spaghetti
this party started several days later he
died
Todd purchased a motel with the proceeds
from selling counterfeit beanie babies
several days later he died Matt's wife
left him and married comedian Katt
Williams
several days later Katt Williams died
it just happens so how could several
days later we know what's gonna happen I
have no idea I don't I don't question
God